[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ça pour ramasser ce que vous avez
pas mangé maintenant vous vous sentez
maintenant vous sentiez vous sentez
on laisse les poubelles partout il y a
des rares partout des odeurs
alors que des poubelles brûlent dehors
en marge d'une manifestation cette vidéo
prise lundi soir dans une pizzeria de
Saint-Étienne fais le tour du monde et
du web surtout parce qu'elle rappelle à
beaucoup ce même
où tout va bien pour ce chien cerné par
les flammes pour beaucoup d'internautes
la France c'est parfaitement approprié
cette scène
Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir
dans l'actualité de ce mercredi 22 mars
l'intervention du chef de l'État ce jour
à 13h en direct sur la première chaîne
et Antenne 2 le président Macron avait
convoqué deux de nos confrères au palais
à l'heure de la pose méridienne un choix
horaire que la députée Renaissance
Fadila cataly justifie comme tel je cite
à 13h on parle aux mamans on parle aux
personnes qui sont peut-être en train de
déjeuner qui seront à l'écoute du
président de la République un moment de
convivialité en tout cas et d'apaisement
l'objectif d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de
dire c'est pas la rue qui commande vous
ne croyez pas que la France est à feu et
à 100 il y a des institutions je suis là
et je ferai adapter des textes c'est
assez logique il dit ça s'il disait
contraire on écoute à tous les chefs de
l'État à tous les
bonjour monsieur le Président est-ce que
vous pensez que ça me fait plaisir de
faire cette réforme dites-le nous est-ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut continuer
avec
les mêmes règles qu'est-ce que c'est le
déficit est-ce que vous pensez que
j'aurais pas pu faire comme temps avant
moi mettre la poussière sous le tapis
oui peut-être oui Laurent vous avez de
la concurrence sur limitation de Sarkozy
Emmanuel Macron voilà qu'on peut
apercevoir au milieu de paruvres en feu
on peut aussi voir en train de se battre
avec des manifestants prises à party ou
alors carrément en train de ramasser les
déchets lui-même sauf que tout cela et
bah est totalement faux ça n'a jamais eu
lieu ce ne sont pas les photos
je pense qu'il y a des gens qui bossent
se laisser avoir sur les réseaux sociaux
oui oui
c'est une influenceuse qui est très
suivie ce matin elle s'est dit tiens je
vais écrire un message au président de
la République voilà ce message
coucou vous êtes là
urgent
ok tu vois c'est un truc important c'est
photos que je vous ai montré d'Emmanuel
Macron elles ont été réalisées à partir
de cette nouvelle version de midjournée
5 effectivement j'ai regardé sur toutes
les photos et bah il a que 5 doigts et
au niveau de la lumière on est plutôt
bien donc c'est une belle avancée
technologique
c'est une belle avancée technologique
mais ça pose quand même des risques au
niveau des fake news les progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle permettent
de créer des images toujours plus
réalistes et d'imaginer l'impensable le
président en première ligne de la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites voire même embarquer par des
policiers la rue a contesté tous les
présidents de la 5ème république des
attentats on visait le général de Gaulle
ou Jacques Chirac aucun chef d'État n'a
échappé à la colère à la rancœur parfois
à la haine du peuple français mais il y
a autre chose qui vise aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Emmanuel Macron c'est autre
chose c'est la rage la rage qui monte
dans le pays la minoritaire bien sûr la
rage instrumentalisée évidemment la rage
irrationnelle certainement mais la rage
quand même le peuple
il faudrait les barricades vraiment mais
il faut pas les barricades des Italiens
sont des gens vous êtes très civilisés
à la télévision le vidéaste misterflash
a donc décidé d'organiser une
manifestation place de la Concorde à
Paris mais dans un jeu vidéo et ce vidéo
c'est Mario Kart
[Musique]
s de football
un dérapage est toujours possible et
tous les jours on dit aussi sur ce
plateau on peut être en compassion avec
ces jeunes
vous savez du président que c'est la
seule chose qui ferait reculer Macron ce
serait un mort dans la rue
oui
c'est peut-être une nouvelle ferme de
greffe qui s'instaure c'est comme si
c'était le trou du cul qui était bouché
et par le trou du cul bouché bah tu vois
le bordel que ça met dans la société je
vais le dire trivialement c'est
interview c'est du foutage de gueule
c'était déjeuner sauna pour Julian en
cette Journée mondiale de l'eau et de ça
je vous le dis
pour des réponses plus concrètes et plus
rapides
c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faut
une fonction absolument essentielle et
je pense que c'est vrai il se fout de
notre gueule pour être très clair avec
le caca de la société on arrive encore à
faire quelque chose
il faut se résigner au progrès
économique et à partir du moment où on
sait résigne il faut essayer au
contraire de l'organiser et de le
contrôler
alors est-il compatible avec
l'environnement mais évidemment il est
compatible avec l'environnement ce n'est
pas simplement le même environnement
qu'avant à partir du moment où elle une
usine ça n'est pas la même chose que
lorsqu'il y avait une bergerie c'est
certain mais ça n'est pas forcément plus
laid
nous avons brisé le cycle de l'eau
détruit les écosystèmes et contaminés
les eaux souterraines notre phrase du
jour est signé du secrétaire général de
l'ONU Antonio gutérus à l'ouverture de
la première Conférence des Nations Unies
sur l'eau la bombe à retardement du
climat fait-il tac voici le guide de
survie pour l'humanité le transport
maritime l'aviation l'acier le ciment
l'aluminium l'agriculture tous les
secteurs doivent s'aligner sur
l'objectif de zéro émission d'ici à 2050
pour limiter les dégâts le GIEC le
Groupe d'experts intergouvernemental du
climat appelle les États à déployer
davantage les énergies propres comme la
voiture électrique l'énergie éolienne ou
photovoltaïque une image incroyable et
inquiétante en Australie celle de le
noir et blanche des milliers de poissons
ont été retrouvés morts dans une rivière
et ce a priori en raison des
températures élevées persistantes